конкуренція тут запікала у поліпшенні
музиканти у мадриді
викладаються на пів ну ти цю музику і
на пуерта-дель-сіль тіла рать тут і на
зимових гостро лоррі та міс цілі таланти
всім хочеться битися роботи в годині кризи
гурт potato млт та штука яшка стінового
ті
лавра надаль владна вчителька у
фортепіано
алаві на ньому вже правоту в офісі сам і
малюка зайняти теми
c запальні дует краю поки що
нелегально а скільки для їх бутік
булочних виступів тепер потрібен дозрів
а щоб відрив від цього куб у квітки за
новим ip риби самий треба з пласти
з-під мерії саприн і зукул їх тобто
восени диво станемо добрий ти граєш про
та іншого tedx булочних музикантом на
волоке зірку чекай на принцип збору
так що тобі на дають хороший туди краще
за вище тис у будинку
тих хто б за ліцензії нарікав встають
накладала ми не міг би у вуличній огорожі
ями зації може влип це 750 євро штраф
з вами поліна мульта доставка контенту та
поліцейські ставок та булочних музикантів
така ініціатива пішла
спалося і одеси билося мадридською
ратуші мері вже двору копіюючи вона сулію
я дружина екс-прем'єра azzaro
консервативно бургомістр q знайду люблю
цю помсту за щоб вона не бралася
своїм ідеям зіпсована бур пливу
критику на витю такі сфери як валочно
музика
тиша може я хочу
люблю музику червона одна справа у концерт
не залитий шива парі через все миша на
вулиці та музиканти а я булочки музиканти
залатали це 8 сорому
проте дусі вчили знайти мадрида на
на заході це гумка їм через чутки а у
своєю музикою байт вже і до і саме у
буринь матриці протестує проти
державних обмажемо у культур не звари
місця мадрид куллу хофбурга
і музою за вуха джо ти просто вийти тули
неодноразово ить аргументація йому дружина
була оскомину
спонтанний протест і з підлоги хуєту
мадриді то тут то там шана ляльки
за вигляд був ася за дружину одна тисяча таких
демонстрацій лаурі краще вигнано не
померла всі три пальці тому плану
проводи ти штрафи до шести ста тисяч
євро за актом протесту білизни папірцем
політики в обидва гелі парламенту
народна партія прем'єра раху я новим і
законом і найгірший вид товарів
бажання протестувати та ліберально
іспанія в край у бурі на наше те що
виходи ми судді з turbo вані але за
розумом соціального конфлікту влада мало
поперек вона в це людей аргументами
карате та законами
порву vantage vue промінь не музиканти лаура
і джерарда поважають що політика жорстка
руки єн забезпечену пошукати я обожнюю
що досьє в нашій Україні в пораду буває
собі потужну мер але в рамадан та закону
снів і вони олл-ін і вдів сіняв цих
іспанією і може забути ти і на боготу
буржуї речі форми протесту та моменту
буде amos
маша лева freeware
з дуру краще без нього авурт potato млт
поки продовжу грати і